a candidate engaged in smut but I say so
what but has her career been eclipsed by
her x-rated Clips the Democratic nurse
practitioner aren't they all running for
office in Virginia is embroiled in a sex
scandal after a pornographic webcam
video she filmed with her husband were
leaked still though some Democrats were
relieved to hear about a leak that
didn't involve Hunter's laptop or Joe's
bladder
according to the Washington Post Susanna
Gibson hosted more than a dozen Live Sex
Shows with her hubby on a website called
ChatterBait which I assume is an online
forum for fishermen it is thank you
she
reportedly asked her online fans for
tips in exchange for private shows
adding that she was raising money for a
good cause well thank goodness Jerry
Lewis didn't try that
R.I.P in another video she also
reportedly said she and her husband
tried swapping but he quote doesn't like
to share
so are you sure she didn't marry a
Republican
Gibson has since lawyered up she told
the Washington Post she won't be
intimidated or silenced although
according to the videos there is one way
to get her to stop talking
[Applause]
she blames her political opponents and
the Republican allies for this leak
which she called a sex crime Republicans
are so outraged they want to see the
videos over and over and over
to make sure they're real I for One
support Susanna and her husband it's not
like they're cheating on each other
they're monetizing their matrimony and
it's kind of refreshing to find a
scandal that involves having sex with
your spouse
for some reason just the idea of having
sex with your husband can be terrifying
what I don't get it I don't get it at
all Lee you told me you wanted to do
this story
Scandal have made you more popular among
New York voters in your bid for governor
I say no
[Laughter]
I agree you uh I think it was Confucius
I don't remember but it was something
about a candidate who screws their
spouse on camera for cash will screw
constituents off camera for cash I don't
know if it's a good thing maybe cat you
know sees it a little bit differently
but I
I think that this is uh you know this is
not a good thing for a candidate now now
interestingly enough and I don't know if
I would call this um admirable but maybe
interesting is that somebody who is
willing to swap with their spouse maybe
is someone who potentially can be more
bipartisan
they're showing a willingness what I'm
saying yes reach across the aisle and
make new relationships reach around the
aisle
over it under it across it whatever
you know what you did all right on this
yeah you know
Pat what do you say about this you know
what's amazing to me is that this
married couple has kids and they I just
feel more boring than ever right
yeah
no I mean I I got who cares I mean
you've got One Life to Live if you want
to live it kinky go ahead I can't
believe that this this doesn't bother me
at all who cares that hurt her husband
do this go ahead and do this the stuff
about her that bothers me is more along
the lines of like oh she wants more gun
control laws yeah that's the kind of
stuff that affects other people do you
want to go ahead and do that then like
looks like she's having a good time so
yeah it's a good point you know this is
overshadowing or I don't even know what
her stance is on it I don't know her
positions
um
[Laughter]
whoa whoa oh man
[Music]
let's see that one coming but it was
good Gutfeld no stop dirty minds he's
not informed okay I happen to know all
the positions okay
she's
on all fours for everything
[Laughter]
to bring everything together it doesn't
have to be missionary sometimes you know
sometimes you just got a cowboy up and
just get those get those things in there
votes and laws yes
what's happening listen if you want to
do stuff with your your
husband or wife and put it on video
listen that's your funeral that's yeah
that's not nice this will be fun and
divorce but
we've gotten to a point where
most people are just happy that it was a
husband and wife and normalized because
if you want to start going there we've
got to cast of characters in the current
Administration that I think would be
much happier if they were doing with
somebody had vows with and putting on
video and some of the stuff we're seeing
like you can't even have your luggage at
the airport yeah you know what I'm
saying like we've got some really
wild weird stuff going on we have we
have principals who who have been
arrested for child pornography like we
have all kinds of stuff going on this is
almost refreshing yeah you know what I'm
saying it's like
it's refreshing it didn't hurt anybody
else except the person who over tipped
yeah exactly
exactly you know Riley I think you're 23
right I am so I apologize I just want to
know what the good cause is what's a
good cause the betterment of our
constitution
do you have any feelings thoughts or
cares about this maybe I have not been
exposed to this long enough but to hear
this is refreshing I I don't know if I
agree with that
um this is um it's an ugly world out
there oh my gosh I'm realizing very
quickly yes thanks Keith olberman
um yeah I I um this is It's a slap in
the face to so many and I think most
importantly the matrimony of what
marriage is in my perspective
um
I think it's a good look for women
though because her sex scandal again was
with her own husband yeah that's I mean
and and Tyrus is right so many gross
things are going on right now and you
talk about Sam Brinton stealing luggage
you got Hunter Biden you got
there's two other people I can't mention
because I live with them
I serve two things but listen everyone
has a little something and it seems like
it's all coming out of their closet and
to be women on this one they get it
right they have scandals with their
husband yeah men have scandals with
other things and stuff yeah Anthony
Weiner and bodies end up pulled out of a
yeah yeah or you bodies end up in a car
in the bottom of a lake you know what
I'm saying like women don't well it
happened yeah
all right I guess we should uh do you
want me to go okay cool just let me know
up next are you a racist jerk if crime
makes you berserk hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else